we'll never be singers Lord and Taylor  Swift both know the difficulties that  come with Fame but in a new interview  Lord opens up about how hard it really  is to be friends with someone as famous  as Taylor the 20 year old tells The  Guardian quote it's like having a friend  with very specific allergies there are  certain places you can't go together  certain things you can't do there are  these different sets of considerations  within the friendship it's like having a  friend with an autoimmune disease sounds  difficult  granted it seems like the two find a way  to make things work back in November  Lorde posted this pic of her Taylor  Swift and Karlie Kloss writing of Taylor  quote you love me so hard I could burst  here's to our three magic years of best  friendship let me live that fantasy  you